on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
well tonight
Putin Reigns Hellfire and civilians in
the biggest bombardment of Ukraine since
the start of the war is this finally our
red line Nicholas sturgeon Associated
test Tories one year on from an MP
shocking murder is this kind of divisive
political rhetoric becoming dangerous
our Superstar magician Penn Gillette
will be here live to talk Trump Twitter
magic and more
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening London
welcome to peterborg in our sensor my
question tonight is simple what is our
red line when we say enough is enough
there are more dead bodies thrown across
the streets of Kiev in Ukraine today
they were just trying to get to work an
elegant Cosmopolitan European Capital
once again Paralyzed by terrorism fear
and grief this is the daily reality for
ukrainians
thank you
what did she do wrong she's just a young
girl probably trying to walk to college
now she's traumatized for the rest of
her life and for what for Revenge that's
pretty much it a huge explosion damaged
the Crimea bridge this weekend we don't
know exactly who did it what we do know
is that Crimea is Ukrainian don't forget
that the bridge is a legitimate
strategic Target Putin's response was to
attack civilians 83 missiles filed
indiscriminately a residential buildings
all over the country a tourist spots or
offices these are war crimes and the
response of the Ukrainian people was as
resilient as ever
[Music]
they sheltered together underground
singing patriotic songs teachers gave
classes in the metro in the face of the
most heinous kind of Terror they came
again once more in defiance they are the
reason Putin isn't winning this War and
why he mustn't win this war they need
our help more than ever
hundreds of thousands of Russian
reservists are on their way to join this
so-called what does he call it I can't
remember but it's a war
they're going to be thrown like logs
into a furnace by the evil dictator
there can be no peace as long as there's
Putin now is the time to call his bluff
it's time to give president zielinski
everything he needs and more to win this
war
well joining me is chemical weapons
expert Hamish to Bretton Gordon from the
head of the British army Lord Richard
and also joined live from Keith by the
investigative British journalist and
author John Sweeney who's been posting a
series of extraordinary videos today
from the Ukrainian Capital John let me
start with you thank you very much
indeed for joining me I was in Kiev uh
in July to interview president zielinski
and his wife the first lady zelenska and
I was struck by two things one that is a
beautiful
Cosmopolitan European city and at that
time they were leading relatively normal
lives and secondly the incredible
determination and stoic resilience of
the Ukrainian people not to give Putin
an inch an inch of their territory
looking at it today with all these
missiles raining down not just in key
but other major cities around Ukraine
what is your sense about where the
moodies of Ukrainian people
oh there's no question you're you're
right Pierce um there is no question at
all that um that anything has has been
shifted people have been killed today I
mean I I
got out pretty early and I saw
um the the cars have been hit and um
there's a road crossing which is in
London terms as busy as the junction of
Hyde Park corner and Piccadilly
something like this then um a few yards
on 100 200 yards on
they put a missile bang next to a
children's playground
and then a couple of half a mile away a
big office block they hit that and
um while we were filming that I realized
that I was stepping in someone else's
blood and the person had been standing
there rushed the hospital but was uh but
died on arrival and then there was
another kind of a zigzag of blood which
which I which I followed
and it was dark as dark can be however
this is I think not a sign of
military strength but a sign of weakness
the reality is the Ukrainian Army is
beating the Russian killing machine
Hollow in the South and in the East and
my friends in the Ukrainian Army are
absolutely
appalled and horrified by what's
happening but one of my Powers is a guy
called vladenchenko who arrested me
because he thought I was a Russian spy
on day two of the war but we said it's
made up but he's sort of said like not
an inch not an inch
uh we're not going to surrender we're
going to keep on fighting and very very
hard
and I think it's a spiritual I wanted
just before you go and I was for the
play a little mashup we did if some of
the videos you've been posting today
quite extraordinary and as a backdrop to
this Keith's mayor Vitali Klitschko who
I interviewed when I was there uh gave
the following details about today's
airstrikes they hit 45 residential
buildings five objects of critical
infrastructure and communal Services
three schools one kindergarten two after
school clubs and five Healthcare
institutions so that is the kind of
thing that the Russians have been doing
today to the capital city of Ukraine
let's take a look at John Sweeney's
videos today
this morning at the height of the early
morning rush hour and Central Kiev the
Russian Center missile and the Missile
hit the intersection
and as you can see there's at least
three vehicles which are coming
completely burnt out there's another two
over there
I fancy the coffee
with what the Russian army is done for
the coffee shop
if you can see this is the children's
playground and that's where the rocket
fell
This Is War Crime After War Crime After
War crime
the people who targeted this missile the
people who hit the button
they should go to The Hague
and so should their Commander in Chief
very powerful journalism John and
congratulations on that you're doing
extraordinary work there under obviously
very difficult conditions
I I believe that Ukraine has to win this
War I I think if you let Putin simply
land grab Ukraine a massacre innocent
people in the way that he's doing with
these war crimes then what does that
what message is that to any dictator
frankly and not least of all him who I
would imagine would just carry on
grabbing lamb back until he's restored
the Soviet Union but I guess a crucial
question is how does Ukraine win uh
zedinski today put out a tweet saying
had a good call with Liz trust the Prime
Minister obviously uh very important
that that relationship with with Britain
continues in the way that it was
fostered under Boris Johnson but how do
you see the ukrainians winning here
oh they're already winning they're
already winning in a very simple way
which is that they're corroding and
eroding the the strength of the um the
Russian killing machine by using the uh
essentially the rocket artillery the
Highmark system which the Americans have
given them and they've been hitting the
ammo dumps and that has taken out the
previous Russian advantage in artillery
so it's switched now the ukrainians can
in boxing terms basically if you've got
a a much longer arm you can hit the
other guy and the other guy can't hit
you back and what's happening is
the other thing is as far as the
Infantry is concerned ukrainians are
completely fired up because they're
fighting to get their homes back and the
Russian army has been told a dark fairy
story that Ukraine is Nazi it's not at
all Nazi the president is Jewish it's a
democracy it's a democracy where people
joke about the president it's that kind
of place it is it's got its problems as
all democracies have but essentially
they are
um this is an open and free society
which is fighting for its life and there
are times like today where it reminds me
of what I've read about London in 1940
what people really want to do is go
drinking and dancing but they know they
have to fight the monster yeah John
Sweeney thank you thank you I've got to
leave it there thank you very much
indeed for joining us I'm sure we'll
want to talk to you again in the week
because you're doing remarkable work so
keep that up and thank you very much for
your reporting
thank you
what I want to discuss now I guess what
the big question on everyone's lips
which is what will Putin do next and if
he decides to launch any kind of nuclear
strike on Ukraine and who can be
anything past him given what's happened
today then how should the West respond
uh well I'm joined by hey Mr Breton
Gordon as I said chemical or nuclear
weapons expand also lordana the former
head of the British Army start with you
hey Mr Bretton Gordon um thank you for
joining me on the show
what is your reading here of the
Potential Threat which President Biden
in the United States expressed a few
days ago this is the nearest to
Armageddon we've had since the the
Missile Crisis uh Cuba Missile Crisis
back in the 60s do you agree with him is
that kind of talk dangerous is there a
likelihood that Putin could use nuclear
weapons of any kind well I think there's
a danger of frightening people against
reassuring them uh I was in Syria in
2013 when the Obama Red Line disappeared
with a massive chemical attack in ghouta
and I think that in Bolden Putin I was
also around Aleppo in 2016 when the
Russians and syrians fought for four
years conventionally and failed to get
anywhere but 15 days of chlorine Barrel
bombs day one so this unconventional
warfare is something that Putin
understands as John and you've described
the conventional fight is failing I do
not agree with Obama that we're face
missing Armageddon I think it was bad it
was by myself apologies they're too many
checks and balances in place he can't
press the red button at a whim but I do
think the issue of Battlefield uh
nuclear weapons is something that he
could use but I think we can prevent
that and the other area is weaponizing
nuclear power stations like zaparita
which again they've threatened I would
like to see NATO be much more forceful
here I hope that Biden and trust and
others are saying to Putin if you move
your tactical nuclear weapons close
enough to Ukraine so they can be used we
will prevent them being fired I hope
they're all how do we do that well these
are on launchers big trucks that again I
have to move a couple of hundred miles I
expect to get them in place and with our
Precision guided weapons these are NATO
ones not Ukrainian ones we could stop
them being used and hopefully the threat
of them you blow them up blow the
vehicles up what happens to the weapons
I carry well without getting too much
technical detail the the weapons don't
actually weaponize themselves till
they're fired so though if you've looked
the thing that was carrying them that
wouldn't detonate the nuclear weapons
there might well be contamination but it
would not be very unlikely to create a
nuclear explosion as if it was used in
the manner that it was supposed to be
used okay let me bring in Lord Janet
Lord Donna I mean just to even be
discussing nuclear weapons is frankly
pretty terrifying for most people uh
when you've got the president of the
United States talking about potential
Armageddon if the situation is not
rapidly cooled what is your response to
this where where are we do you think in
reality with Putin
well what we're seeing is the reality
that Putin's experiencing in the present
moment he is lashing out in a fairly
well not fairly a very in a very
ill-disciplined way and his reaction to
the Crimea Bridge attack
with the 80-yard attacks right across
Ukraine is a sign of desperation from
him at the present time now the question
that you're debating is whether he'll be
tempted to go nuclear Hamish has pointed
out the difficulties that he's got but
actually think about another practical
element if he was going to use a
tactical nuclear weapon and Soviet now
Russian Doctrine uh
includes Battlefield use of small
nuclear weapons he would do it in a
situation whereby the ukrainians had
suddenly broken through and made a big
attack now let's say it happened in the
in the north on the sort of hakive axis
um if he was to use a weapon against a
Ukrainian formation he would be striking
them and killing a lot of Ukrainian
soldiers but in one of the provinces
that he's just actually declared to be
Russian so he'd be radiating part of his
own country so he's really got to weigh
that one up himself but I think the
other point is that we've seen the
Americans in particular supplying very
sophisticated long-range very accurate
weapons but there are further weapons
that are available that if he was minded
to use a tactical nuclear weapon we
could we don't have to reply with
nuclear weapons ourselves we could use
Conventional Weapons of huge lethality
range and accuracy
um I've said it before I think if I was
a sailor in the Black Sea Fleet I would
not sleep very happily in my bunk
tonight because frankly if we chose to
sink ships or all the ships of the Black
Sea Fleet we could probably do it so
there there is potential pain of a
conventional nature that could be listed
on putting and he's got to weigh that up
is he crazy no we have to hope that he
retains a sufficient degree of
rationality rationality to actually work
out that it's not in his interest to use
nuclear weapons but what is our moral
position here given that he has just
reigned indiscriminately 80 odd missiles
from very long range all over Ukraine
into civilian areas schools and health
centers and so on killing innocent women
children all his usual targets at what
point do we have a moral duty to do more
than simply arm the ukrainians and
actually get directly involved ourselves
we keep being told we can't get involved
NATO because he may mucus but if
actually the reality is he's unlikely to
do that why aren't we actually engaging
with with Russia more directly
well I don't believe that that is the
right response and what would the right
the right response is to go on doing
what we're doing and do even more of it
um yes you're quite right what what is
our moral position our moral position is
to be outraged by the attacks that he's
carried out today and he may well remind
you to carry out again in the future but
that outrage that moral outrage has got
to be translated into a determination to
make sure that the ukrainians have got
even more Weaponry of a greater
sophistication sufficient ammunition
also provide air defense systems to
protect themselves from incoming cruise
missiles and missiles such as came in
today but the main point is and John
Sweeney was pointing this up earlier in
his in his film the Ukrainian Army is
now prevailing on the battlefield and
we've got to help them maintain that
momentum the weather may change that may
well have an arresting aspect to it but
the ukrainians the balance of force has
switched from the Russians to the
ukrainians we've really got to go on
supporting them arming and training them
and training is so important there are
as I'm sure your viewers know thousands
of Ukrainian soldiers being trained in
the United Kingdom and they're being
trained in such a way that they can go
back to the battlefield and they can be
successful whereas the
um conscripts that are being drafted
into the Russian army are getting very
poor equipment very poor training in
fact they are just going to be Cannon
footer the we've got to back the
ukrainians to continue their momentum to
continue their attacks to push the
Russians at least back as far as the
positions on the 24th of February and
possibly even further no done it as
always thank you so much for your
commentary much appreciated and to you
Henry Gordon really appreciate you
coming thank you very much we'll still
become Nicholas sturgeon says uh that
she has no regrets after saying she
detests Tories but is that kind of
divisive rhetoric really what should be
acceptable Ian Blackford who is the head
of the SMB Dennis and joins me next to
discuss and we'll pull a rabbit from the
Hat the Superstar magician Penn Gillette
joins me live in the studio always a
lively guest we normally end up arguing
I'm just not quite sure what about today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back after the train wreck of
the conservative party conference today
was returned to Scottish national party
to set up their vision for the country
the Nicholas surgeon that Visions are
divided one the s p literally got a
standing ovation for saying a new
Independence referendum should go ahead
and next year but a speech was
overshadowed by comments she made to the
BBC's Laura coonsberg yesterday
the question to me is would I prefer a
labor government over a Tory government
I detect the Tories and everything they
stand for so it's not difficult to
answer that question
and here she is well today doubling down
well I apologize for saying that I don't
support and don't much like the policies
of the conservative party no I won't
I've got GTA's first minister to stand
up against Nicole surgeon thank you for
joining us wasn't exactly what you said
though was it first Minister you didn't
say you'd tested the policies of the
conservative party you said you'd
attested Taurus well joining me now is
leader of the Scottish national Party in
the House of Commons Ian Blackford am I
packed for tonight entrepreneur and
farmer Wilfred Emmanuel Jones freshman
joined appearance on the BBC question
time show normal newspaper editor Emily
Sheffield and lawyer Paul at Rowan
Adrian welcome to all of your Stellar
pack tonight so thank you for joining me
Ian thank you for coming all the way
from Westminster it's a pleasure to West
London from Aberdeen via Inverness
exactly I appreciate the long journey
you've made um Nicholas sturgeon saying
she detests Tori she can pretend today
she said I detest their policies but we
all heard what she said on the BBC she
said I detest Tories politics is about
passion peers isn't it we're all
passionate you're passionate and then
the rest of the pan are passionate I
think there is genuine anger about the
impact that Tony policies I've had in
Scotland you know we had a report last
week from Glasgow University as a
consequence of austerity they've been 20
000 excess deaths in Scotland over the
last eight years three hundred thousand
out of the UK I think that's where you
get justifiable anger I don't think due
to test stories I don't detest anybody I
see no I don't no I don't and that's not
a a value that I think is a Vladimir
Putin I well okay so there are limits I
want that man I want that man here too
that believe the test team but my point
is should anyone in Nicholas sturgeon's
position
actually say on the record I detest
everybody who votes conservative no it's
reminded me of Hillary Clinton calling
Trump supporters a basket of deployment
it's not that's not what the what the
first Minister said I mean you had the
clip and I think for me there's a very
clear influence there it's about 20
policies about 20 politics and you know
what she said that's my point she
actually said I detest stories no she
doesn't say Tories
what's the difference so there's no
there is a difference
and you and I understand all that
clearly you're a lawyer now dealing in
Samantha and every everybody else who is
reasonable understands what the
difference is
she's talking about the party that's
what she's talking about she's not
talking about an individual who's in the
party
so but look why not I'm losing the party
people right who are these people she's
talking about tourism
breaking ranks uh in a moment but what
the first Minister did say at the
interview yesterday that of course they
shouldn't worked with the Prime Minister
when it's but it's permissible to do so
all of us have to work together but I
mean the fact is I give the example of
the excess deaths but you know we're in
the situation what's she wrong though to
use the phrase I detest the tourists
look people there is genuine anger about
the impact
yeah what was your boss wrong no to use
such an inflammatory rhetoric and let me
point out today is a year anniversary
since a conservative MP was murdered I
look and all of us right second MP to be
100 years well so all of us rightly call
out
any kind of abuse which has meted out to
anybody whether it's a politician or a
journalist and I think it's incumbent on
all of us to raise the standard of our
political discourse but that doesn't
mean that you can't have what she wants
to use that phrase I think look in the
context of what I said to you about you
know the excess deaths that I talked
about the fact that we don't have we
don't have obviously wrong to use the
phrase I think in the context of
everything that's happened I think it's
appropriate for the prime for the first
minute do you agree with it but I mean
people will behave in in their own way I
will certainly
is your boss she is my boss he's the
leader of the party she is indeed and
she's now said I detest the Tories it
didn't she I thought you yesterday
distance yourself up and said you
wouldn't say that now you appear to be
saying you wouldn't no I'm not I I was
asked a question yesterday but I would I
would I would speak in that way I'm a
different person I fully support this
how are you different you know all of us
are individuals all of us behave in a
different ways that was that's what
makes it really think what he said was
wrong no no no no no no no no that's not
that's not what she wasn't wrong no I'm
not saying that applying it what I'm
saying to you is that they're talking
yourself the tourists have an enormous
damage to Scotland I've given you that
example the situation we don't have we
don't have respect
I think the Tories have done a lot of
damage down here never mind it's
Scotland right but I wouldn't say that I
detest the Tories because actually
there's a large large number of Tories I
I had to test the impact of 20 poly
that's the difference I think and I
think in essence that's what the first
Minister was referring to it's the out
was it is it irregressive that your
whole conference has started with a
debate about whether what she meant by
this because it must it must be it must
be annoying even I think we've had a
very successful conference and I think
what I hope we now do is we concentrate
on the the arguments for Scottish
independence
just one last try was she wrong to say I
detested I I fully respect the the right
of the first one let's just play it
again and see if you feel comfortable
with this this is what she actually the
question to me is would I prefer a labor
government over a Tory government and I
had to test the Tories and everything
they stand for so it's not difficult to
answer that question okay
I detest the Tories and everything they
stand for everything they stand for
that's quite a statement everything is
stable do you Ian Blackford a democracy
do you genuinely stand by that statement
okay or could she have phrased it
differently I I want to get the
situation that we can have respect and
the is that respectful well well look
we've got a situation that the prime
minister of the UK has not met with the
first Minister it hasn't met with
leaders of the opposition I'm not
surprised she just said to test the
tourism they stand for and then look at
the kind of things that Elizabeth saying
in the 20 leadership election campaign
as well so let's let's have a sense of
balance and proportion we could go a
long way to be honest to get into that
place that you want to get to and I
applaud you if you wanted to get there
if people like you who actually run the
SMP down here in London if you just said
you know what actually the first
Minister shouldn't have used that phrase
it doesn't help when when a leader of a
party uses such inflammatory language
about a whole body of Hurricane when
you've got a situation the electricity
bills have doubled in a year I get all
three people are facing problems no
one's questioning we've got the increase
in mortgage costs that are going to come
through of course the people people are
angered by the the employee so say what
she said today which was very cleverly
crafted differently to what she said on
Sunday what she said today was I I don't
like Tory policy our beef is what the
conservatives have done to Scotland and
that's what the debate should be about
in fact the the ball not the not the men
women gives a football terms uh then I
absolutely agree you and I are football
fans and that's exactly what we should
always be doing we finally got that and
now Wilfred uh Emmanuel uh Jones
businessman founder of the black farmer
we were on question time we had a
similarly torturous route to an apology
and we're from Nadine zahari let's have
a look at this
what I haven't heard from anybody at
senior level in this party in the last
10 days is one word sorry sorry to the
country for what you have put the
country through you want to say it you
said that word you said no I'm going to
tell you I'm going to tell you Liz said
I've listened and I get it you cut and
you move forward you've got 24 most of
them
walk with blood Vladimir Putin want us
to do he wants to be divided right now
because he's losing energy oh come on
nothing people are laughing countries
around the world are having to raise
interest rates with respect what does
this have to do with a simple apology
for the train wreck that has happened in
the last 10 days I said to you Liz in
her conference we said I get it and I
and I I'm sorry I changed the policy I'm
sorry of course I'm sorry thank you
oh we got there in the end
um you've still got time if you want to
indeed on behalf of the party you seem
to have called a taxi for me
let's turn to our pack um Wilfred I mean
I I have to say I would have respected
Nicholas I do respect her as a leader I
think she's extremely competent uh
probably the most skilled political
leader we have in the country and I've
always felt that and she often comes on
and faces the music in tough interviews
which again I respect but I have to say
that when I heard us use that phrase I
winced and when I heard a double down by
pretending she'd said something else I
thought she was being extremely
disingenuous and I would respect her
more if she simply said you know what on
balance having thought about it I
shouldn't have said I'd attest the
Tories I actually did test a lot of
their policies
you tried your best tonight to get an
apology yeah and we you demonstrated
that you're not going to um say any more
to it but there's a serious issue about
this it is dangerous language
what we one of the things that I'm
getting really concerned about in terms
of our politics is the aggression to say
all these nasty things means some idiot
some not to as we've seen happen in the
past may take a cue from your leader and
then think that would be an excuse to go
and do something pretty nasty when you
see politicians are now being attacked
but if you when I was up in Birmingham
and you just see the aggression coming
from people now if it's allowed that the
the leaders who use that sort of
language do not apologize in a sense
that's giving people permission to start
using this sort of language it's a
serious Point these are these are these
are really important matters and I've
I've spoken out on numerous occasions
over the last few years about where our
political discourse is the threats are
there the the deaths that we've had of
of two MPS over the course of the last
few years that all of us individually
collectively have got a responsibility
to raise the test
yes and of course and but I think you
know in the context of the question that
the first Minister was was asked it was
an appropriate way for her to respond
but look I want all of us I'm only
surprised about one thing that actually
you don't just say I don't think she
should have phrase all that because I
know you yourself have now said you
wouldn't have said such a thing so you
clearly believe it's not a right thing
no no that's not the case Pierce because
everybody has has their own way that
they behave I personally wouldn't do
that because that's not why wouldn't the
person I am because I you know I I you
know given the person I'm in the
language I would use I would hope that I
was wrong there is nothing wrong with
saying that because what I'm what I'm
saying is the the first Minister's
reflecting on what she sees as the
impact of Tory policies in Scotland I'm
just surprised that you wouldn't say it
because you clearly think it's wrong I
don't think I was wrong I I detest what
is the outcome of the of the politics of
the conservative party in in Scotland
and I want to have that debate about how
we change things for the better but you
know I think it's because there's lots
of really important things that we need
to discuss and of course we need to make
sure that people are safe let me be
absolutely clear about that and the
obligation we all have is the incumbent
on all leaders to dial down the rhetoric
yeah I I I I I I you know I said that I
think it's um it's wrong that our
political discourse has been colored but
you know I'm you know I'm not going to
talk about me but you know the kind of
abuse and the threats I've had along
with others I also know you said in July
you said in July this year candidates
hoping to replace Boris Johnson make
Genghis Khan look like a moderate okay
biggest challenge just for the benefit
of the viewers was responsible for
murdering 40 million people and reduced
the entire world population by as much
as 11 would you stand by your yeah and
again you have to look at that in the
context I was doing it prime minister's
question and it hasn't exactly worked
out well the changes
a scale of millions of people I didn't
certainly compare anyone to mass
murderers made him look like a moderate
so presumably 40 million is moderate
answer your question Pierce because at
the end of the day again your canvas
quite a right-wing right-wing individual
and the fact is that we've had a a
neocon uh right-wing agenda from the
conservative party over the last few
weeks which has done enormous damage the
fact that the bank of England
the interest rates are going in this and
I agree with you so there's huge damage
which I agree with you about this I just
think on I think that caught in the
context
that's a number 10 Aid also repaired
referred to Michael Gove as a sadist
this weekend I don't think I I think
there needs to be a dialing down
everywhere we've just come through I
honestly I think it's so abhorrent the
electorate as a whole that we're seeing
people who are meant to be leading the
country throwing insults left right and
Center these are people who are meant to
be uh representing us abroad and here I
am and I have to say I I'm shocked that
I might be I might be sticking up uh in
this line of argument But the irony of
being on peers uncensored and asking you
are we censoring Nicholas sturgeon what
she did what she did I'm not saying
she's not allowed to say it I'm
surprisingly about how she felt I'm
really surprised wouldn't say he thought
it was wrong when he clearly thinks he's
wrong no I don't think it's wrong you
think it's wrong but I explained I think
in the context well you wouldn't say by
yourself who do you think is wrong yeah
you know because everybody has their own
way of expressing themselves and I think
the first Minister was absolutely right
in the context of the the questions that
she was asked well I mean I've explained
that and you know people use Lang
language the way that they think is
appropriate and it was entirely
appropriate for that question squeeze
the lemon before we let you go just
quickly on Scottish independence
what is the end game here if you don't
get to where you want to get I saw the
sturgeon at the weekend basically saying
you know if the Supreme Court doesn't
rule in your favor then you're going to
use the next election result as a
validation of Independence but that's
not how this works as you know you can't
do that right well look at the end of
the day I mean I'm mentioned a bit of
respect from Westminster and the fact is
the SNP we haven't had a conference for
three years we've won the last three
elections we've actually been in power
in Scotland since 2015. you didn't win
the referendum and you and you you'll
know nearer really in the polls to the
the Scottish people agreeing with you
about this two things or one is if you
look at the polling last week actually
support for Independence was up but I
get the point that we have got to show
demonstrably that people in Scotland
want to become independent I think we've
won the right to have the referendum one
of the things we did over the course of
the last few days because I know you all
want to talk about how we pay for it how
we make Scotland a successful country
I've published a plan oh my god
well there you are you see you give me
some details do you think it's
but the point is this is a plan to
increase our energy green energy over
5'4 385 000 jobs 34 billion of an
investment into the Scottish economy by
the end of the period including people
to work that is a if only paraphrase
that is a plan for growth and your
position and your position remains as
far as I'm aware at the SMP that you are
implacably opposed to
what the UK did in leaving the European
Union Yes but you are also implicatively
opposed to staying in the United Kingdom
well look because the things that we
need to do what did you understand the
slight contradiction to support
let me say to you that in every decade
since he's stronger in a union week not
true because every decade since 1850
Scotland's relative population within
the UK has declined I went to break that
I want to change that I have a plan
which is based on economic growth that
will create opportunities drive up
living so you know what and we'll become
a beacon for success
thank you for coming in and be just by
having that plan that lives a lot more
detail than the one less trust in kwazi
had last week I congratulate or at least
having something in front of us
basically coming in thank you very much
we'll keep the pack here we'll talk
about Kanye West we're going from one
rebellious Troublemaker to another he's
been suspended by Twitter and Instagram
over anti-semitic terrain what does this
mean for free speech when does it become
hate speech is it right that he's been
known Factor plus the much bigger half
on legendary Duo M and Teller Rockstar
magician angelette is live
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
we're back with my Superstar pack I want
to read you a tweet from Kanye West
that's led to him being de-platformed
from various social media entities
overnight he said I'm a bit sleepy
tonight but when I wake up I'm going
Defcon 3 and he's about death d-e-a-t-h
Con 3 on Jewish people the funny thing
is I actually can't be anti-semitic
because black people are actually Jew
also you guys have twidded me and tried
to blackball anyone whoever opposes your
agenda uh his Twitter accounts now have
been removed his account's been locked
so Paul my question view is twofold
really one is it right it has been
platformed and two when he says I can't
be anti-semitic because black people are
actually Jewish too what do you make of
this okay so answer to your question
number one absolutely he should have
been de-platformed what he was saying
was completely out of order completely
inappropriate broke every policy that
any normal natural Humanity human being
would want in place in terms of
protecting you in terms of any racism
prejudicism
um so absolutely right to have deep
platformed him can I just add a b to
that this man is clearly not well why is
no one seeing this yeah I think people
are seeing it just heartbreaking your
last thing yeah right I'm listening I
agree but Emily the problem is he's got
millions and millions of followers on
social media he is clearly going through
some kind of episode I think from his
behavior in the last few days so is
there a responsibility there for the
social media platforms to make that kind
of judgment cool about people in the
public guy who might be having some sort
of episode
I think that's a very hard thing to get
into right because then you're asking
then you're then you're asking them to
start judging what someone's mental
state of mind is so I don't is it right
I think because of what he said yes that
is it's purely anti-semitic
um I don't see how but if if they
allowed that through we can't then
complain when they allow sort of you
know we've just had a case where they've
Met has been accused an Instagram of
allowing a young girl the young girl
you can't have one and not the other
just because he's famous well friend we
we actually had children at the same
school so we go back a long way
um and this Molly Russell case has been
very close to my mind with with the
Kanye uh incident actually because I do
think social media uh companies have got
to be a lot tougher now about what they
allow to be put in their in their
platforms because for example when I run
a newspaper if you publish something
like this in your news but you've been
serious regulatory trouble so it seems
to me they have no choice but there are
people all over social media today
saying what about his right to free
speech that if he wants to say that why
can't he I don't believe in censorship
so this sounds very controversial but I
don't because one of the things that
struck me was the interview you did with
Andrew Tate right and I just think what
we need to do is that we need to trust
people to be making the decisions rather
than somebody else saying we don't think
this is good enough
right so imagine if I started tonight's
show by saying I'm a bit sleepy tonight
but when I wake up tomorrow I'm going
Defcon 3 on black people okay so what I
would what would you say now 100 seconds
what I do um I would say my edits I
would say right we're going to put this
program in and then you'll have an
announcement there may be things in this
program that something no I don't like
it I don't know well Twitter's live you
just put it up
D E F he said d-e-a-th that's a clear
threats but but there are so I said that
about black people without any type of
people but black people for example yes
I don't think your view about don't
censor it would have stretched that yes
there are but people know there are
certain people that's going to be
controversial they come and they're
going to doesn't mean they can say
whatever they want well that's not what
Free Speech you know it means and when
I'm not talking about free speech at the
moment what I'm I'm talking about
censorship you will know that there are
certain people that's going to have a
view so if you decide to listen to that
person knowing they have a view well
that's your problem what I want to do is
that I want to leave it to people to
make their decisions rather than some of
those things anyone can say anything
they like on social media is that your
position
both ways you said Nicholas sturgeon
needed to dial down on the rhetoric well
yes but she's a politician now we have
this man she has nowhere near as much
influences exactly exactly but do we
know he has with young black males
because people are it's a bit like
Andrew Tate
and therefore people making decisions
based on whether this guy was talking
sense or not do you think most of the
people who saw an interview would have
thought this guy was right in their head
but Emily has come back to me on this it
seems to me this is a clear threat he's
making here we don't know what the
reality of that threat is but I'm going
Defcon spelled d-e-a-t-h-3 on Jewish
people I just don't think that should
ever be allowed in a public social media
platform and they're private companies
they can do it alike and I would
normally be hot on the case of
censorship but to me this is just pure
hate speech
I think it is I I mean not I think it is
and it that I I as I said earlier I
don't think you can have one rule for
one person because they're famous and
we're all sitting there going fine we
all know it's Kanye right it's not
feeling very well because then how can
when Molly Russell's dad took the case
against meta for why his daughter was
seeing these images which they believe
then led to her committing suicide
you've then got no protection absolutely
and so that that is that that is I think
it's really when you have extreme
arguments it's very easy but you know
it's for me who decides what is censored
well I think I think anyone I think
honestly anyone that reads that from
someone like January yeah that to me
crosses the line
to answer we decide to be racist
whether we actually listen whether we
watch rather than telling rather than
somebody says you are not allowed no no
I hear the point and I've argued that
many times myself there has to be a line
though there has to be alive and the
resides on the line well I think we all
know what anti-Semitism looks like when
you're making threats against Jewish
people and they've we know the history
we have laws as well that you can't
wander around the street yelling racist
or anti-semitic things so it follows
that Twitter which essentially is a
platform which allows you to shout at
lots of people that there's got to be
we're going to use those same laws in
place we've got the perfect person to
talk about this pendulate one of the
world's great Libertarians I talked to
him after the break about this is a
really interesting issue where does Free
Speech meet Hayes Beach and what do we
do about all this thank you to my
Superstar pack great to see you thank
you very much indeed and Juliet next
there he is the great man he's here
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back my next guest is Magic he's
one half of the legendary Duo Penn and
Teller a Global TV Superstar they offer
a new crime novel random and pendulation
great to see you good to see you with
you many times never in this studio it's
great to have it really nice first of
all want to talk about uh tell her your
great friend co-star has just had 47
years big heart surgery he had a
quadruple bypass and I got to tell you
shook me up more than it did him you
know two days later he was in physical
therapy where where were you when it
happened uh he was at home in Las Vegas
and uh it's really remarkable I as I was
walking out of the he's in a rehab so
labor they're doing physical therapy the
all the nurses took me aside and said
we've never seen anybody like him he's
like a week ahead of where he should be
two weeks ahead and I said well he's
he's tough yeah but he's going to be
okay oh yeah there's we'll be we'll be
back end of November later and uh scary
for you terrifying terrible did you
think for a moment you may lose him well
uh there was no reason to think that but
I thought that you know what I mean all
your fears go through your head yeah
well please send him my very best I
certainly will and on behalf of all of
the viewers too it's good so much to
talk to you about but first of all this
issue of Kanye West what he tweeted
being no platform this whole issue of
social media censorship what's your view
about it it all comes down as usual to
me being wrong you know and I I remember
being in a seminar at MIT at the end end
of the 80s early 90s talking about how
when you'd had total free speech and
everybody had access and looking at this
as kind of a Utopia I had never crossed
my mind that we'd find a way to to
monetize shock and hate and outrage and
once you've got those in their
algorithms that are in place to monetize
that I don't think of course he should
not have said that shouldn't be no
platform for it ah these are private
organizations they can take them off and
they probably morally you think is it
the right call
where do you think that line with free
speech and hate speech begins and end I
think that if you're talking morally
it's absolutely reprehensible it should
never be said who decides that it
shouldn't be said as a heart is a hard
issue but the real problem seems to be
much deeper in that we found a way to
reward that kind of thing and of course
with uh with our mutual acquaintance
Donald Trump we saw that that got
rewarded and rewarded rewarded you know
I don't care what they say about me as
long as they talk about me that was
always kind of nonsense but now it seems
very close to being literally true
should social media firms like Twitter
like Facebook like Instagram is awful
case of this young girl who was
bombarded with imagery about suicide and
depression because she was looking for
stuff about suicide and depression in
the end the Court ruled that it ended up
contributing to her taking her life it
seems to me it's a bit of a wild west
still you know when you run a newspaper
it's regular you run a TV show they're
regulated but the the social media is
just completely Lawless the whole uh the
whole thing is uh there's got to be a
way to change it so that that's not
rewarded and I don't think it's really
tough to say we want to have a board or
a government doing this but uh private
companies I mean Twitter can have
anybody off there they won't you can
allow anybody you want on your show you
can decide you're deciding all the time
in a way it's a form of censorship by
who you decide to have enough yeah you
decide you've decided that 7.6 billion
people won't be on your shoulder what's
going to happen with your country in the
next election is Donald Trump going to
run again should he run again would it
be good or bad for America we've
actually had one candidate run for
president while in jail it was the
Communist candidate in um in the uh
right after the first world really you
can legally run in the United States
should Trump run again would it be good
or bad for America for America terrible
awful I mean we we worked with him uh
you and I I think that uh one of them
many things we agree on uh some we
disagree on but many things agree on is
he was wonderful as a television
character but did either one of us think
he'd be a good president I never thought
he'd be present a million years and in a
way you know his instincts were pretty
good the rhetoric was a lot of the
problem with Trump uh well what I think
was the problem was the complete and
utter lack of Shame yes and I don't
think he has a shame valve no no I don't
think he has an empathy valve or a shame
I certainly got a lot of support never
heard him uh sincerely laugh at a joke
no it wasn't at someone's expense yeah
and more importantly uh kind of
poetically never saw him tap his foot to
music
did you ever see him like no but now you
mentioned it that is creepy I totally
agree really creepy talking to people
tapping their feet to music you you're
about to replace Simon Cowell on Britain
yeah
you're far too good looking to replace
especially Christmas on Britain's Got
Talent sitting you fat probably in one
of the old chairs I used to sit on as a
joke yes yes and it'll be uh a two-hour
Christmas special all magicians and I
think I know all of them so it'll be uh
it'll be wonderful because they uh they
really shoot magic very well yeah and
I've seen the list of who they have on
and they are wonderful brilliant well
it's it's strange isn't it how our
Worlds Collide uh I've interviewed you
around the world you're not going to be
judging the show I judged for four years
and it's great to see you and I will try
to fill your shoes
good luck Miranda the book oh thank you
our hair is great it's great to see you
send all our very best to celebrate I
certainly will good to see you that's it
for me whatever you're up to keep it on
since good night
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]